في جريمه صايره في المانيا واخبارها ماليه
العالم والسبب انه الجريمه عجيبه وتدافع
بصراحه اعجب يعني طبعا ما في اي مبرر بشكل
عام القتل هذه يعني خالصين منه هذا
الموضوع يعني لكن هذه سببها ما يخطر على
بال احد اصلا فخليني احكي لكم القصه مثل
ما صارت في عائله في المانيا من اصول
العراقيه بنتهم طلعت وما رجعت فرح بلغه
الشرطه بفقدان بنتها الشرطه اشتغلت تدوير
على البنت وفي الاخير لقيت سيارتها في
غابه وجثه البنت مرميه على الكرسي الخلفي
ونادوا الاهل اللي تعرفوا على البنت وبدات
تحقيق في وفاتها وكيف ماتت خاصه لانه
البنت كانت مطعونه 50 طعنه والشهامه
الاهل تعرفوا على بنتهم من لبسها وهيئتها
وسياراتها والشرطه بدات التحقيق يعني لكن
مفاجاه الصاعد كانت لما جاء بعد كم يوم
نتيجه تحليل الدين وطلعت البنت مو بنتها
طيب مين هذه
بشويه بحث من الشرطه حددوا هويتها وطلعت
فتاه جزائريه وبتشبه بنت العائله العراقيه
بشكل كبير طيب فانا البنت المفقوده هنا
بدات تتكشف تفاصيل الجريمه العجيبه الشرطه
اكتشفت انه البنت اللي وقتها كانت ضايعه
يعني وافتكروها هي الميته اكتشفوا انه هذه
البنت عندها مشاكل وخلافات مع اهلها فقررت
بالتعاون مع احد من اصدقائها من قصبه انها
تعمل فيلم على اهلها وتعمل كانها ماتت
وتهرب هي عاد مع صديقها هذا بس علشان
تقنعهم انها ماتت بتحتاج جثه وهي اصلا
بلوجر فبدات على انستغرام تدور على بنات
شبهها
وتراسلهم وتحاول انه تصاحبهم وترتب لقاءات
معهم وفشلت اكثر من مره لكن اخر مره مع
الفتاه الجزائريه ظبطت معها وهو فقدت
البنت انه تلتقي فيها على اساس الموضوع
اتفاق بخصوص مستحضرات تجميل ولما نلتقوا
فيها قتلوها 50 طعنه في وشها عشان يخدعوا
الشرطه والاهل بالجثه عموما الشرطه لاجت
المجرمين
وقبضت عليهم واللي بان بيواجهوا طبعا
السجن ماذا الحياه اذا تمت ادانتهم
[موسيقى]